[Music]
what's up guys welcome to the show
this week we have a really special guest
I'm really honored and delighted to be
sat next to Martin Roberts you've
probably seen him from the TV
he's been hosting and presenting on
homes under the hammer for 16 years he's
written some fantastic property books
yet some incredible training programs so
welcome to the show Martin Robert well
it's nice to be here there you go
fantastic really glad to be stuck next
to your some of the content that you put
out there is just absolutely fantastic
well you know you talk about 16 years
it's hard for me to believe it's been
that long but it is and we're still
carrying on we're carrying on filming
now and the kind of things that I've
seen over that time well are you can
only imagine I'm sure yeah absolutely
so how long have you been in property
you've ended in homes and have over 16
years so you know I like a lot of people
started out just doing the few little
bits of pieces on the house I owned okay
so I was born into a house where my dad
was into his DIY and he was always doing
bits and pieces so if something broke or
if the kitchen needed being replaced he
would do it so when I got my first house
I naturally did that so we had not
through a few walls I put in a new
bathroom but a new kitchen at the same
time I was starting my career in the
media so I was working for a local radio
station and over a two-year period I
probably earned about 35 pounds from
doing the media stuff literally I was
paid 25 pounds a week okay working in
the radio station that I was working on
at the same time in that period I did
the work on the house and sold it and it
had doubled in value and I made 25 grand
and that was one of the penny dropped
and I certainly thought her a minute and
I think this is the paradigm shift that
people have to take you know property
isn't just a roof over my head it's
something that can actually make me
money and provide a genuine fair honest
way of making a living and I think once
you make that switch at once you then
learn the ways to do that properly
it it it's it's a great thing to do but
I was brought up in a house where it was
all about property I think if you come
up and if you brought up in that
environment then it still takes a bit of
a leap but at least you've got a few
skills at your fingertips yeah so you so
you made like a thousand weeks profit
yeah
by mistake yeah so it's like I was like
I think you can make a lot of money in
property by mistake so if you deliberate
imagine how much more you can make on it
exactly and you know and there's almost
take you the step to doing this again
and again and again and again is the
trick and that's us I guess what
separates professional property
investors from people who just do it on
the odd occasion with their own house
and it is odd isn't it because most
people if you ask them would say well
okay what's made you the most money in
your life in litter well it might be mad
well I should my house them those in
value why did you really do that once
then yeah I mean but but it's taken that
step and a lot of people don't yeah so
are you actively buying properties today
yeah because you've got some projects
really interesting projects going on
tell me about the most interesting
project you've personally been involved
with so the one I'm really excited about
at the moment is its that why would say
is the holy grail of property investment
where I've got a bit of land which has
got a derelict building on it but it's
in it's outside the development boundary
it doesn't have any planning permissions
it doesn't have much more than a 1%
chance of turning that into something
that I could build on but I'm currently
putting in planning permission for
creating something which is
architectural II innovative and
outstanding so I have along with my
architect over a few bottles of wine
come up with why consider to be my dream
house on a hillside in Devon and in the
next few weeks hopefully that is going
before the planners and they will see
what I've created is is a statement of
architecture in 2019 and if I get that
the the amount I paid for the land is
absolutely piffling compared to all it's
worth so that's right it is the holy
grail of super exciting so you've been
doing homes the hammer for 16 years
think about that is you've been watching
and learning from other people again and
again and again and again what would you
say to someone I mean I read this
property auction guide recently and
that's what encouraged me to reach out
to you because to be honest this book is
absolutely insanely good for anyone
that's looking at buying from auction
it's not something that I've got loads
of experience with auctions I have have
done it
talk to me a bit about 2019 what there's
there's different ways it's probably
there's auctions there's estate agents
there's buy-to-let there's developed
loan what's the best strategies you
think right now for property so I think
if you to sum up the property world in
2019 one word it would be uncertainty I
think out there people everybody you may
like I don't know and yet people who do
it for a living and have been and lived
through uncertainty before or even lived
through terrible times in like 2007-2008
when it all went horribly wrong right
we've lived through that then we are
slightly more stoical about where we are
and you know I think if you
intrinsically believe in property as the
investment strategy and as a thing to
put your money in then then then just
because there's breaks it or no breaks
it just because you know the front page
headlines are saying this is saying that
it doesn't matter you've got to stick
with what you believe in and I believe
long term a medium term as an investment
vehicle you can't be property okay and
so I am I'm carrying on you know
regardless and through it all and
actually there's a great quote from from
Warren Buffett he says that bad news is
actually an investor's best friend
because it enables you to buy a slice of
the future and a discounted price so
while everyone else go you're going I
say well I can't quite give you what
you're asking but I'll give you 25% less
of that because I'm taking the risk here
because you know everything might you're
horribly wrong
you know Minh you can turn any any
situation I believe if you're
professional about how you do it
into into a positive you talk about
auctions right the thing that's still
started me about auctions is only 6% of
the properties in the UK are sold by
auction the 94% of properties land
commercial opportunities are sold at
auction so and yet if you know a bit
more about auctions which is one of the
reasons why you know I'm delighted to do
the show and also why I wrote the book
if you know more about them then you can
maybe cast aside some of your
misconceptions maybe throw aside some of
your fears and realize that the
positives outweigh the negatives and
there are some amazing bargains at
auction not all auction properties are
bargains but a lot of properties that
are sold at auction are bargains yeah
one of the things I think about auctions
is if you don't know what you're doing
auctions are a lot more risky to manage
it would you would you bro the thing
about auctions is that it happens
frighteningly quick okay and when you go
to an auction and you put your hand in
the air and you bed that is a legally
binding contract you have exchanged
contracts there's no thinking about it
afterwards so unless you get all your
ducks in a row lined up before you
begged which you must do finances you've
seen the property check the legal pack
you make sure that it makes sense in
terms of clear in terms of is it fit for
purpose is the property okay
structurally all those kind of things
unless you put all those ducks lined up
then you are heading for a disaster if
you're buying through other means you
we're very well some would say it's
extremely annoying
the way that the normal we're buying
houses works in that you sort of say
yeah I'm kind of interested in that and
then you conduct surveys you you you you
think about trying to get financed you
you know you think about it for six
weeks while the listeners on holiday and
two or three months later eventually you
sign on the dotted line you've got lots
of chance to make sure that you do the
right thing you know at auctions you
have to do all that preparation
beforehand but the plus side of it is if
you get the mindset of auctions and do
all those things you are on then you
benefit from the fact that
four percent that people don't go to
them so you can actually genuinely they
got some stuff that's like you know
literally twenty thirty percent under
market value I know you you run training
programs yep what do you think that you
really need training programs in order
to be successful I mean what why is that
important to you so I wrote a book
called making money from property and
out of that came the making money from
property trading course through through
legacy education and that's a three day
course where you we literally take
people through you know the beginning
starting point setting up you business
all the way through to raising finance
to actually finding properties and
da-da-da-da-da and one of the reasons
why I wanted to tell that course on is a
lot of people look at property and they
think I could do that
you know but I need to pay to go on a
course and that's like it's going to the
state edge you know there was some money
you know you wouldn't say that about any
other profession you wouldn't stumble
into being a doctor or you won't stumble
into being a solicitor you'd you would
invest in yourself yeah and you would
learn to do it properly because sure you
might be able to be successful but the
guarantee is pretty much on the side of
you messing it up if you haven't learned
how to do it properly and professionally
so that's what the training course is
all about they they teach you how to do
it properly you know and how to run it
like a business and do it professionally
I think in some ways the fact we were
also familiar with buying property it's
almost like we take it for granted but
there's a big difference in between just
buying a house and doing it properly as
a business it's a bit like the
difference in between your son or
daughter falling off their bicycle and
you putting a sticking-plaster on then
the it doesn't mean that you can do a
brain surgery operation you know yeah so
you need the trainer and there's a lot
of there's a lot of people out there I
want to pay them that's like well any
money you put into it you'll get my
tenfold because you are investing in
yourself and your knowledge and and and
you know following the advice of others
who have been successful yeah I think
that investing in property is probably
the second best investment after
yourself well yeah absolutely
completely in any and any NNE sphere and
so I'm a huge believer in it and which
is why which is why I do it and it's
really nice when people have been on the
training courses or people have seen me
on television and they've said you know
we followed your advice and now we are
financially free or we're whatever and
it's really lovely when you hear those
stories that success as a result of what
asked you earlier or off-camera which is
that was really interesting as I said
when are you gonna retire when are you
gonna stop with the training and writing
and running homes into the hammer you
don't need to do that you know you've
been you've you're a very successful
property investor winning your stop and
your response was you'll stop when you
stop love doing it and I think that's
really profound yeah I mean I am blessed
that I do do a job that I really love
you know I don't wake up in the morning
go only I don't like everyone you wake
you know and sometimes get off what
we're going to get through today but in
general yeah I love what I'm doing and
and you know I always said that I'd stop
in homes and the hammer way that I went
out when I arrived at apartment on the
bottom of this and I even after 3,000
properties which is what I've done 16
years you know each property still has
something special about it I still love
the property so I love seeing what
people do with stuff and meeting people
and their aspirations and you know and
you are constantly surprised and some
things are very humbling just a couple
of stories one about the reasons why
people do it I bet this one couple and I
said to them you know why you why you
investing this money in this house and
they said well we support an orphanage
in Africa and we looked at the most
effective way of us raising funds for
that orphanage and we decided that if we
bought a property at auction and we did
it up and we sold it and we put all the
money that we made as a profit into that
orphanage it was a quick way of giving
one to that to that charity rather than
rattling tins outside a supermarket or
going on a bike ride for charity
whatever so that's exactly what they did
and we went and we revisited them and
sure enough they're done at this
bungalow that sold it's a 40 grand
profit and all that money had gone to
this orphanage in Africa so
the profit they gave it away and
everyone's reason for doing stuff
raising money becoming financially free
can be different and they're all they're
all varied and they're all valid but I
think sometimes people think outside the
box like that and it stops you and me oh
my gosh they're doing it to give it away
ain't that great that's right and and
the other story which was was definitely
sent me in the the crew into tears and
I'm not being the rat here but I really
have difficulty telling this story
without going cry upset we were in it
and it's not setting the bad away but
you'll understand when I show it to you
we're gonna have some Stockport and I
said to the lady wire why you body
butter sounds and she said well sadly my
mum passed away six months ago and in
the latter stages of her life we used to
sit in the hospice together watching you
talking about me on television and this
my mum said to me I will die in the next
few months and I want you to take some
of the money that I'm going to leave you
and I want you to do what this man
pointed to me on the television is he's
telling you to do and there we were in
this house it stopped but that she'd
bought as a result of of me on the telly
and it was almost like a mum's spirit
was there and she'd followed through
what a mums last wishes were and it was
like oh my golly
that's what you realize the power you
have and the kind of way you'll fete
people's lives that's that's a big
privilege right that's massive
absolutely massive what what's your
purpose now I know you're involved you
do a lot of charity stuff what's your
big reason now so I do do a lot of
charitable stuff I you know I consider
myself quite privileged to be in the
position amateur celebrity I don't
consider myself aside like a celebrity
celebrity I'm going to in like hello
magazine and stuff like that but but I
am known and I've been part of people's
lives for quite a long time on
television and I think that does put me
in a position of privilege in terms
you've been able to give back and help
protect you so I do a lot of charity
auctions I help various charities from
animals age which the moon bear charity
and at the NSPCC obviously the children
started then then that's sort of
developed into
my own charity which is the Martin
brothers foundation which is has been
set up in the last couple of years and
and its job is to support safeguarding
and education initiatives for children
and young people and it's project - its
first project is is this book which I've
written called SADS ville and it's we're
raising the money to give a free copy of
this book which encourages children to
be aware of their own emotions and helps
them deal with their own emotions quite
an early age this is aimed at sort of
eight nine year old children in
conjunction with the NSPCC saying you
know let's let's let's let's learn a
little bit about what emotions are and
how we deal with those emotions and
recognize sometimes it's okay to be sad
you know your holiday ends your best
friend moves away yeah you know maybe
the pet dies you're very sad but it's
it's sort of it's okay sad and there's
another thing I call it good sad it's
not good but it's it's part of life and
there's nothing bad sad which is you
know you're being abused you're being
bullied you know you're under
psychological pressure from somebody you
know whatever it might be so it's
getting children to recognize that so
literally we're raising the money to
give a free copy this to everything like
nine year old in the UK and so far we've
raised the money to give out 7,000 books
across Somerset twenty-two thousand
books in Hampshire and we're looking for
people who can help us with a relatively
small amount of money that we need I
mean to cover the whole country is only
250 thousand quid you know and if you
pick it up for County or an area it's a
lot less than that and then it gets the
word out there and hopefully I mean my
raison d'etre is this you know I will
never know if this stops some young
person from being abused or worse but on
the assumption that you know if just one
child is saved from abuse or the kind of
stuff that the NSPCC see all the time
then as far as I'm concerned that's
priceless isn't it yeah you know I mean
and my job has been done and then that's
what I call the legacy this is a legacy
and the houses are great and and all
that other kind of stuff but to actually
to actually be doing this means a lot to
me and you're a father of two yourself
so I've got a nine year old and a twelve
year old and I think if you are a parent
anything to do with abuse or
any kind of pain that children go
through you would I think even more
passionate about trying to do whatever
you can to stop because you know every
every child deserves a a childhood happy
you've got a great heart I love what
you're doing and that's why I wanted you
on the show so one of the things that
you're really passionate about is
helping people get into property so that
they can then live out their legacy and
they can then do their charity stuff
yeah what advice would you give to
someone or what I'm an ask yourself if
you were starting from scratch all over
again and you only had say 50,000 pounds
2019 with more in Roberts brain all your
experience and knowledge but just 50,000
pounds starting again from scratch what
would you do with that 50,000 pounds so
I mean I guess I'm going to say a
predictable answer which is I would look
at the auctions
I really would even start I'll guess
your experience because I see stuff you
know we were in South Wales last week
and there's two up two down Terrace he's
pretty decent stone built up tilted down
terraces 40,000 quid okay you could
start with that and you could do that up
it's worth 70 so hold on hold on hold on
break this down so you're gonna put
about 40,000 in yeah you might even if
you pay a penny less miss stamp duty yes
exactly so so 40 grand in spend about 10
grand on it and then it could be worth
up to sell it refinance it
so in an ideal world I would refinance
it especially in this market man yep and
because the yields you're getting in
those kind of areas what let you know
hello one a forty thousand about to even
fifty thousand investment house looking
at four hundred ninety five pounds five
minutes look what's realistic then if
what's realistic but possible to buy it
for forty spend ten on it yeah and then
refinance it what seventy-five yeah that
realistic yeah and then pull out what
all your money yeah you do that regular
yeah this book this book
dude this books good you know what
auctions auctions I do auctions I buy
from options I bought I told you I was
telling you the story of the castle
castle of what castle has never bought a
castle
ah fears me about talking about auctions
on my youtube channel is that all I know
people that you know what it's like you
get emotionally drawn in yeah
you've paid for the survey yeah so
you're invested yeah
your emotions are higher your
intelligence is low mm-hmm you've got
the auctioneer yeah using all these
little tricks in the book yeah and what
happens is people end up paying their
you know you know that's what fear so so
that last kind of my warning on auctions
which is why it's so important to read
this book yes well thank you and you
very kindly said it is one of the best
property books you drew I did you know
what this book all right I'm saying this
from my heart not because you told me to
say it
this book is better than my book my book
is very good but this book honestly dude
this book is so good I've made all my
stuff and I reading this book my brother
who see over somebody is reading this
book and you can get this on Amazon
yes operate from my website the auction
guide yeah by Morton Roberts it's just
that's that's that's very clearly be to
say so so but it is so you write by as I
said before the big thing about auctions
is you know it's a one-way street in
terms of when the hammer goes down you
are buying it there's no thinking time
there's no Oh whatever's now thenns not
the time to send the documents to the
solicitors to have a look at to make
sure they're all right
it's too late there's no get out clause
yeah but other than waving goodbye to
your deposit and the other thing was if
you pull out about option purchase and
it's subsequently resold for less and
you accretor bought it by four then you
are liable for the difference so it's a
terrible terrible situation get into so
there's lots of caveats to it which are
worn you need to get finances in place
and you still you can get normal finance
on an auction property but obviously
what's against you is your time right so
you want to be looking at an agreement
in principle based on you as a person
and then you will approach the mortgage
companies and say you know this is a
property I'm thinking of and they will
give you an idea of what they would
potentially finance up to if you if you
need to buy through you're using finance
you need to make sure that you've seen
the property you need to make sure that
yes you've checked it out with somebody
knows what they're talking about and a
lot of people say well I might be
looking at 10 you know 10 properties how
can I have them all sir
well I say build a team of people around
you who on the journey with you right so
yes if you were to pay a an average
surveyor to go and serve a house for you
it's gonna cost you 607 and whatever it
might under quit and that gets expensive
you look looking at ten properties but
if you're going to be doing this a lot
why not go to that survey and say look
here's the deal
I pay you 200 quid for a survey if it
doesn't go to that shebang I'll pay a
thousand quid if it does yeah right so
you get that in with you because you
don't want to be going in there without
having a service it's a mad it matters
but you some deal with somebody and then
they'll buy it so that may be a big firm
of surveyors might not but you get you
know a local surveyor who comes on on
your journey with you nothing's okay
fine
children quit in two thousand quid if
again you know you come to a point
really oh yeah how do you think the
great thing about the 2019 people's
uncertainty right now is you can buy
below market value campuses and you
couldn't do that two three years ago
chuckles you couldn't do that from the
front line okay this is really insider
information if you like because
obviously the show homes in the hammer
is is that all the auctions right now
so there'll be firm you know an auction
in Birmingham today and also in London
tomorrow and auction in Cumbria the day
after that so we are actually there at
the auction so I can give you an
overview of absolutely what's happening
in 2019 at this point in 2019 and say
that the auctions are a barometer of the
housing market and so not surprisingly
it's a little bit sticky
you know the auctions are not the
numbers are not going up like the money
and especially in places like London but
I see that as as a buying opportunity
because for sure you know you got less
people bidding hallelujah as long as
you've done your research
it's your strategy as well all I'm doing
that from estate agents and from
geometry properties right
so you do buy a property add value to it
and refinance it and pull all your money
out you don't need to go through
auctions now yeah actually no this is
just one buy a house yeah
it's the house that that's ultimately
good I was telling you about my
financial freedom challenge and you were
saying how can you build a portfolio we
can you buy a house into it yeah you're
gonna watch the video there but anyway
one of the things that I am an advocate
for is that I believe that with the
right knowledge I believe that anybody
regardless of your financial situation
now you can start in problems if you've
got the right knowledge yeah I started
as a teenager I didn't have anything but
I got myself on the right training
program just got myself a good party and
became educated and I was able to build
a portfolio starting from scratch yeah
so what do you think about that and do
you think that because if you add 15,000
pounds if you could then buy a property
and pull it all out presumably if you
didn't have the fifty thousand pounds
you can just borrow it from somebody
that did yeah so what do you thoughts on
that I think people need to think
laterally about that starting point
because that's the hardest thing for
sure right because people can have any
money it's like okay alright well that
means necessarily have to be a barrier
do you know anybody like relatives
friends you've got money sitting in a
bank or group of people or how much do
people trust you well it's just me a lot
okay so you've got five mates in each
give you ten grand
yeah and you say I'll give you a share
the profits I'll do all the hard work
but this is my strategy
you put a business but not to a bank to
you makes down the pub yeah you know and
what do we face that what one of their
options for their ten grand or their 50
grand or the hundred grand sitting in a
banker Billy's decided to put it in
stocks and shares maybe what kind of
returns can they guarantee if you can
show them a business plan maybe that's
another way of getting money linking up
with other people forming partnerships
yeah you know making sure that that's
structured legally because it's alright
making forming a partnership with a mate
or a heir would be fine we'll share the
costs we'll share the profits you need
to have that written down then make sure
that it's properly signed and then put
away in a draw but you know link up with
somebody to share the risks you know
link it was somebody with complementary
skills maybe you already good at
sourcing stuff on the internet maybe
you're great but you actually really
rubbish it dealing with builders or
whatever it might be
find somebody who has complementary
skills and going with them you know
there's lots of different ways again
that that first watch of of money and I
think that is what people sort of find
is a huge barrier I need to save twenty
five thousand pounds before I can even
start yeah and how long in this day and
age with all the drawers on people's
money especially when they started out
how long is it going to take you to say
25 grand that are taxed income a long
time for those people I mean most
people's mindset is work hard save money
put it in the bank
one day if you're old enough and wealthy
enough buy a second property but
actually that's completely skewed but
there's me right but when I was 19 years
old 20 years old working I thought to
build a career and okay the careers
turned out really great but I was only
25 pounds a week and accidentally yeah
at the same time I was doing this thing
we don't even think about it do not this
house in stock poor and fired it up
generated me 25,000 pounds in the same
amount of time all right you know 2,000
quid so it's like oh so without
realizing it I was I was making the
money through buying to their what I
always say to people as well is what
what is what have you got that's not
going to cost you anything and and and
and something which first time is
especially I've got and that's time and
energy so it's do as much as you can on
doing a property yourself yeah right you
clearly can't do well actually can't do
gas but most people could have a go and
most of the stuff there's so many you
know videos on YouTube and books about
how to tile a bathroom or whatever you
know could currently that's because you
don't have to pay for your time the
moment you start bringing in builders
who are charging you whatever they're
charging then you especially when you're
starting out all those all-important
bits of profit go by the wayside so when
you start out especially the thing
you've got is your own time and
enthusiasm so so don't try and find the
perfect property find something you can
actually do up yeah you know I think
it's of course everyone's got a
different strategy haven't than a
difference
duration but it's good advice one of the
things I often say is people think that
the most important thing you need is
money then probably knowledge and then
the least important is network and I
think it's reverse I think that your
network and your power team is the most
important and your knowledge and your
money money money we were in living a
resort resourceful price yeah well
there's a lot of people who've got money
of it don't know what to do with it I
mean in the nicest possible way so you
can go but you need to be professional
about it and that's that comes back to
the training right it's like approaching
it professional yeah okay it's a
business it isn't just you know this
isn't just the fun that you do in this
property you need to you need to set it
up you know you're venturing it in a
professional and businesslike manner I
need to run it in a professional a
businesslike manner and if you don't
then how can you expect it to be
successful one of the common questions I
get asked is if people if you've got
money sitting in your own house and your
equity in your own house can you use
that and how do you use that to then
invest in property so the most important
thing in all of this is that you
shouldn't do something that makes you
lose sleep at night okay you shouldn't
and there are people who take huge risks
and maybe it pays off but there's
probably a lot of people currently
hitting the Southern Comfort 11 o'clock
in the morning who took too much risk so
when it comes to taking money out of an
existing asset you need to be really
sure that that does not put you under
financial too much financial pressure
however why should you sit in the happy
knowledge that you've got a house is
worth a hundred grand that you owe no
money on when maybe you could draw out
50 grand at that and still afford the
mortgage if all else fails what's the
worst night if everything went
completely wrong could I still afford
that roof over my head when you you know
parent all back you know you might have
a portfolio of a hundred properties
actually you only need one that's for
you and your family so as long as you
can always end up with one that's safe
then everything else you know follows
that but with that caveat why have that
money sitting dead in that in that in
that property when you could take it out
and and invest it in in in other
properties or projects and that you know
it's called gearing
isn't it yeah it's where you know you
you know okay well I've got a half
summers the underground but maybe if I
had if I took out 75% of that money I'm
now got 75 grand and then I put 25 of
each of those 75 grams into a 50,000
pound house now okay a 50,000 grand
50,000 pounds you're gonna have
difficult to get the mortgage of it but
that's just for example for this sake of
this example 25,000 of that into three
new projects which you financing to the
tune of 50 percent if they're 50 grand
each you are really using that money and
also diversifying maybe in terms of the
kind of properties you by diversifying
your risk spreading your risk and still
being in a situation where if it all
went horribly wrong you'd still have
your house with a 75 different mortgage
on it but you could afford that yeah
that's a great answer and I think
because I often see people that have got
no mortgage on their house but then
they're working 50 hours a week for two
grand a month yeah and I can't do this
it's like we'll just just use that money
better you know so it really makes sense
all right far north as we begin to wrap
up final words of advice and wisdom then
what would you advise your 25 year
younger self I don't know how old you
are exactly so when they were starting
out what were the best piece of advice
property wise that you could give your
younger self who's just starting out I
remember working on a hospital ward
there's a rip Hospital radio reporter
and I used to go around the woods in one
of the wards you know I had to go around
was ones where it was later life wards
and I remember and he said he said some
words because I thought were absolutely
so profound that they've stuck with me
since and they could with lots of
caveats but he said do it now
mmm do it now whatever it is do it now
you know what we most of us put things
off because it's a lot easy to put it
off then deal with it and do it now but
you know what if you've got some piece
of paper what you don't want to do on
your desk you know stuff lit around go
nailed it tomorrow each time you put it
down you've corrected yourself a whole
shed load more stress and if you're
thinking about buying a property going
on - well I haven't completely ticked
all the boxes
maybe now I'll have another cup of
coffee and hobnob you know we'll deal
with it next week
you know do it now mmm do it now
whatever it is get it done the caveats
are make sure you make the right
decision you've thoroughly researched it
you know you've got all your ducks lined
up and you know to the best of your
ability you're doing the right thing but
don't fear failure because it happens to
us all and if it doesn't kill you it
makes you stronger do your best and
don't let the fear of failure stop me
doing anything because otherwise you
failed I love that that was powerful the
books the charity stuff it's fact I'm
sure everyone's going to get a copy of
your property auction guide they should
so my websites Martin Robert stuck out
at UK all the details and what I'm doing
is on there how do we how do we support
this so well if you're a business or
just somebody who thinks this is a
project that you like to be involved in
getting contacted me or the foundation
it's the Martin Roberts Foundation
Martin Robert foundation.org got UK and
you can sponsor you know a thousand
pounds here two thousand pounds there if
you want to sponsor a county it's like
10 grand you know anything you can do to
help me get this into the hands of
children who it could help then I'll be
eternally grateful I'm really grateful
for you coming up giving up your time
coming all the way down to my office is
in Wolverhampton and appreciate your
friendship and thank you ever so much
Martin it's my great pleasure
[Music]
[Music]